nous sommes en direct ce soir avec
alexis poulain éditorialiste politique
arte france et arnaud benedetti
rédacteur en chef de la revue politique
et parlementaire bonsoir à tous les deux
merci d'être en direct sur rt france ce
soir première question pour vous avec
six poulains êtes vous pour ou contre ce
report de trois mois des élections dans
le cadre du report je suis plutôt pour
parce que je pense que compte tenu de
cette épidémie dont on ne voit pas la
fin ce vaccin qui n'est pas prêt
d'arriver peut-être au premier semestre
ce serait difficile de faire campagne
pour des élections au mois de mars dans
un cadre normal de campagne donc reporté
au mois de juin trois mois de décalage
c'est pas choquant ça permettrait
d'avoir une campagne qui serait sur le
terrain qui serait incarnée et ça ne
changerait pas tant que ça je veux dire
de mars à juin
il n'y a pas un énorme différence on
parle pas d'un changement d'année ou
d'un d'une annulation de sélection donc
trois mois de décalage pour assurer la
bonne tenue et de la campagne et de ces
élections
ça me semble est une sage décision votre
avis arnaud benedetti trois mois
hypothétique puisque le virus on ne sait
pas ce qu'il en sera dans trois mois oui
enfin qu'il est clair qu'aujourd'hui les
conditions manifestement ne sont pas
réunies pour pouvoir tenir ses élections
et en l'occurrence on a vu lors des
dernières municipales que la pression
sanitaire a vraisemblablement empêcher
de faire campagne notamment dans les
derniers jours et surtout à altérer la
sincérité du scrutin donc la sagesse ou
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui que l'on prenne
une décision très rapide d'ailleurs
c'est ce que préconise je crois jean
louis debré en l'occurrence et qu'on
acte un report de ces élections mais
bien évidemment un report de ces
élections dans des délais qui soient
raisonnables c'est à dire qu' il faut
que ces délais n'excède pas quelques
mois
nout repasse pas comme on a pu parfois
l'entendre dire non j'en veux pas en
tout cas l'élection présidentielle de
2022 d'ailleurs ce qui poserait je pense
un problème d'ordre constitutionnel
occurrence il faut rappeler ce que sont
que ces élections départementales et
régionales d'alexis poulain ce ne sont
pas des élections qui passionne
véritablement les français parce qu'ils
les connaissent mal finalement
l'abstention a été énorme pendant les
élections municipales donc le vrai
risque c'est d'avoir une dégringolade
total de l'abstention oui enfin une
augmentation de l'abstention parce que
effectivement le dé facto notre système
de vote dans les élections
intermédiaires fait qu'on est passé au
vote censitaire quasiment quand on
regarde la sociologie des votants ce
sont des gens qui sont dans la classe
privilégiée culturellement mais aussi
financièrement qu'ils vont aller voter
les gens les plus précaires les plus
pauvres ont abandonné l'idée même de
voter dans ces élections intermédiaires
et on le voit bien
l'élection qui passionne qui fascine qui
centralise tous les intéressés
l'élection présidentielle et même là
l'abstention est énorme
donc on a un vrai problème de fond parce
que c'est un droit fondamental c'est le
droit essentiel du citoyen c'est le
droit de vote et ne pas l'exercer
c'est accepter finalement que arrive
tout et n'importe quoi dans ce pays
abandonner ce droit là ça en dit long
sur le malaise démocratique qui existent
aujourd'hui en france et rien n'est fait
pour endiguer ce malaise qu'il faut
faire c'est certainement pas ce vote par
correspondance mais c'est comprendre et
faire comprendre combien ce droit de
vote est essentiel est consubstantielle
à ce qu'est la république et à ce qu'est
être aujourd'hui un citoyen français
s'est pas seulement s'apitoyer sur
twitter regardez la télé s'informer donc
c'est voter c'est fondamental ce droit
de vote est fondamentale et donc il faut
à la fois raccrocher les wagons avec ces
classes les plus populaires les plus
précaires qui ne voient pas l'intérêt de
voter pour beaucoup et leur dire que non
le vote est essentiel parce que les gens
qui sont élus décident à votre place ou
en votre nom
selon ce que vous ayez voté et donc si
vous refusez ce droit là alors tout est
possible
vous avez parlé du 10 votes par
correspondance alexis poulain arnaud
ni des tice est aussi une des pistes
soulevé dans ce rapport évidemment sur
les modalités du scrutin qui serait
différente à cause du virus donc dont ce
vote par correspondance qu'en dites vous
au vu de ce qui se passe aux etats unis
alors déjà oui en effet il ya le timing
aujourd'hui de ce qui se passe aux
etats-unis qui ne plaident pas forcément
pour la réintroduction du vente par
correspondance dont il faut rappeler
qu'il a été supprimée en 1975 parce que
justement il donnait lieu à des
contestations voire à des froids de donc
aujourd'hui je ne suis pas sûr que cette
modalité de vote soit la modalité la
plus adaptée ne serait ce que pour
ramener les électrices et des électeurs
comme je l'entends dire parfois par
certains parlementaires verts vers leur
tour cilic vers le retour en tout cas
devant les devant les urnes est ce qu'il
faut bien comprendre c'est un principe
qui est un principe républicain qui
avait été forcée par les laisons
politique de la troisième république
les dirigeants de la troisième
république il avait considéré que pour
que le vote puisse s'exprimer
vous allez dire de manière tout à fait
autonome en pleine liberté il fallait
que ce vote s'exprime sans aucune forme
de pression
qu'est-ce qu'on a inventé % l'inventer
ce qu'on appelle isoloirs ya avec
l'isoloir la nécessité pour tout un
chacun de pouvoir en conscience que
lorsqu'ils rentrent dans cette isoloirs
d'échapper à toute forme de pression
pour pouvoir exprimer
et dire finalement calé son choix donc
rien jusqu'à présent ne remplace pour
garantir in fine est un exercice du vote
qui soit un exercice de haute qui
échappe à toute forme d'interférences
que cette modalité là alors rappelé on a
bien évidemment donner la possibilité
par le biais des procurations qui sont
un peu plus quand même sécurisé même si
on voit que parfois sur les concurrents
il peut y avoir aussi des contestations
on
récemment encore dans les élections
municipales
mais il est clair que aujourd'hui le
retour du de l'idée d'un vente par
correspondance
non seulement risque de poser des
problèmes de temps sur la régularité du
scrutin mais ne constitue pas une
solution pour ramener les électrices et
des électeurs devant les urnes parce que
le vrai problème aujourd'hui c'est la
question de l'offre politique
donc ce n'est pas par des moyens
techniques qu'on voit là qu'on va
ramener des électrices et des électeurs
encore une fois devant devant les
bureaux de vote les critiques qui
garantira un moment donné qui garantira
un moment donné le retour des électrices
et des électeurs taille de l'offre
quand on voit ce qui se passe aux etats
unis l'offre n'était pas non plus
extrêmement fin nous passionner pas
véritablement les américains auraient ya
quand même eu un un nombre inespérée de
devoto grâce à ce vote par
correspondance avec ses poulains qu'en
pensez vous je suis pas d'accord je
pense que ce vote a passionné les
américains au contraire on voit bien le
nombre de votes qu'il ya eu c'est un
score inédit y compris pour donald trump
le perdant et pour joe biden le gagnant
il n'y a jamais eu autant de
d'américains qui ont voté pour ce
président parce que ce n'était pas un
vote pour élire un président c'était
quasiment un référendum pour ou contre
donald trump à ce que vous remettez une
pièce dans la machine ou pas donc je
pense qu'il ya eu une vraie alors en
france oui on aura en aura mais c'est
systématique en france depuis on va dire
nicolas sarkozy
le sortant par avec le sortant le
président sortant par un peu avec cette
idée de dire bon bain tout sauf le
sortant c'est un peu ça c'est comme ça
françois hollande s'est retrouvé
président c'est comme ça qu emmanuel
macron arrivant en contender et évitant
les écueils de la primaire s'inventant
et ce faisant inventé candidats grâce
aux médias la façon dont a été créée une
personnage d' emmanuel macron en
quelques mois et il arrive à faire un
hold up de l'élection présidentielle de
2017 en 2022 clairement il y aura un tir
de barrage assez fort contre emmanuel
macron compte tenu de ce quinquennat qui
a été à la fois
extrêmement difficile qui a fait
exploser les inégalités et qui
maintenant est encore plus compliquée
avec la crise sanitaire du covin donc
par correspondance moi je suis
absolument contre tout simplement parce
que c'est quelque chose et vous l'avez
très bien expliqué dans la bastille dont
il est très difficile de tracer en fait
la façon dont ce vote est fait à la fois
s'il n'y a pas eu d'influencé extérieure
si l'identité peut être vérifiée et
toutes ces choses là font qu'aujourd'hui
de votre par correspondance c'est
l'assurance de bourrage d'urnes pour
n'importe quel parti et particulièrement
si votre parti est au pouvoir et que le
ministre de l'intérieur qui est garant
des élections que fermer les yeux sur
certaines malversations
donc aujourd'hui on doit tout faire pour
éviter que des pratiques qui seraient
potentiellement dangereuses
rappelez-vous aux municipales à paris
le clan tiberi avait fait voter les
morts c'est quelque chose de possible
déjà avec notre système qui n'est quand
même pas aussi avancé donc la
procuration déjà permet de faire voter
les morts alors imaginez la
correspondance et c'est d'ailleurs ce
que clame le cran trump aujourd'hui ça a
permis de bourrer les urnes
alors on attend les preuves on attend
bien sûr les enquêtes de justice mais
les malversations sont nombreuses à
chaque élection et là c'est ouvrir la
porte à encore plus de facilité de
malversations or un scrutin quel qu'il
soit doit être le plus juste possible et
refléter la vie des populations et je
suis d'accord avec arnaud benedetti
quand il dit que ce n'est pas la
technique ou les techniques même si on
parle parfois de blog shane de vote
électronique etc qui vont pousser les
électeurs aux urnes
c'est effectivement la politisation des
générations c'est qu'est ce qui fait que
des abstentionnistes ou des jeunes qui
sont endommagés en droit de voter vont
aller voter plutôt que se désintéresser
des élections et bien c'est l'intérêt
qu'on donne à ces élections et bien qu
est ce qui fait qu on donne de l'intérêt
aux élections c'est parce qu'elles ont
un enjeu essentiel et l'enjeu qu'on va
avoir et c'est sur c'est ce qu'on ne
voit pas dans les élections
intermédiaires
lorsqu'on est là dans des élections
locales régionales départementales
municipales où on ne voit pas forcément
même si municipal peut-être plus parce
que on comprend bien que ça peut changer
la façon dont on vit dans une ville
région c'est plus abstrait mais à un
pays une présidentielle là c'est clair
et je pense que ce qui est important
pour 2022 c'est la politisation de
génération et de profils
abstentionnistes au delà de reporter les
départementales et régionales certains
disent il faut déconnecter c'est
départemental et ces régionales arnaud
benedetti est ce que ce serait aussi une
bonne idée selon vous écoutez je ne suis
pas sûr que ce soit une bonne idée en
l'occurrence que l'on couple les
départementales et régionales il n'y a
rien de choquant puisque ce sont des
élections qui concernent des territoires
donc je ne suis pas sûr que la
décorrélation en l'occurrence ce soit
une solution
moi ce que je crois quand même c'est que
les sélections départementales peuvent
mobiliser et les élections régionales
aussi il faut voir que par exemple dans
l'est dans un certain nombre de
départements ruraux le l'élection
cantonale constitue un rite républicain
qui est particulièrement inconstant en
plus que des conseils départementaux un
certain nombre de contrats des votes
sociable qui sont importantes
je crois que le véritable enjeu de toute
façon aujourd'hui pour l'exécutif
il est double il y a un enjeu où on sont
très bien qui a exécuté deux situations
n'est pas n'est pas à l'aise avec ces
élections à venir en l'occurrence qu'il
s'agisse des régionales et
départementales
parce que tout simplement l'offre
politique aujourd'hui de la majorité
notamment du côté de la fenêtre d'un
marche et une offre politique qui n'a
pas réussi sa racine et politiquement il
y a eu certainement un moment donné
l'idée qui a germé dans les couloirs du
pouvoir d'essayer de faire en sorte que
ces élections justement en jambes
l'élection présidentielle clairement la
plupart des présidents la grande
majorité l'immense majorité des
présidents de région ils sont opposés en
plus il ya vrai sans manquant une fois
un problème constitutionnel qui se
poseraient
si le report de ces élections allaient
au delà de jeu de mai et de juin 2022
ça c'est le premier point deuxième fois
je pense qu'il lui doit être doit être
pris en compte c'est que en effet on
voit bien que l'expérience des
municipales a montré que sur ce sujet là
il y avait eu un vrai un vrai problème
l'exécutif a très mal géré les
municipales il a très mal géré les
municipales parce que tout simplement il
n'a pas pris à temps la décision qu'il
fallait prendre c'est à dire
vraisemblablement au moins un mois avant
le premier tour donc il faut qu'il évite
absolument
en tout cas de se retrouver dans une
situation de ce type et qu'il puisse
très rapidement apporter une réponse aux
élus régionaux
on en reparlera merci beaucoup on n'a
plus le temps malheureusement alexis
poulain pour avoir votre point de vue
sur cette corrélation ou pas merci
arnaud benedetti d'avoir répondu ce soir
à nos questions sur rt france